In the unit, we talked about a greedy approximation algorithm for vertex cover.
Let's review that very quickly.
So if we were to implement this algorithm in a function called greedyvc,
the first thing we would do is go to loop that checks that not all edges are already covered.
Within that loop, we're going to first choose a vertex that has the most uncovered edges
and then we're going to put that vertex into the cover.
Now, another step, you might choose a different vertex for this--
depending on how you traverse the graph.
If you have multiple vertices that all have an equal number
but the maximum of uncovered edges in the graph.
So your order with this might vary.
So I'd like you to implement this entire algorithm in the function greedyvc,
where you get an adjacent c matrix as the input.
Now, as output, I'd like you to return first the size of the vertex cover and then a list
containing all of the vertices that are in the cover.
And again, we're not going to worry about order here because you might get a different order
than what we get and we'll check for that.